Trigg means triangle and Metra means to
the measurements and triangles and
specifically what we're going to be
working with are the ratios of the sides
in a triangle so when we talk about
ratios we're talking about a fraction
we're comparing one side to another side
as a fraction so when we talk about
trigonometry what comes up as the sine
cosine and tangent ratios so this
acronym is a one that you're going to
want to memorize it's easy to memorize
it's the so kha
Toa acronym and what it stands for is
that the sine is the ratio of the
opposite side over the hypotenuse the
cosine is the adjacent side over the
hypotenuse and the tangent is the
opposite side over the adjacent the way
I like to tell students about this is to
think of it as the second letter divided
by the third so it's adjacent divided by
hypotenuse opposite over adjacent now
we're also going to learn about the
reciprocal
okay ratios which the sine and the
cosecant these are reciprocals of one
another the cosine and the secant these
are reciprocals of one another and the
tangent the cotangent these are
reciprocals so let me show you what I
mean let's do an introductory example
and we're gonna get into three other
examples so say you're given this
triangle right here it's a 3 4 5 right
triangle we're working with right
triangle trigonometry right now and you
can see this angle theta okay they
usually use a Greek letter when they're
talking about angles or they use a
vertex like a ABC like for example
you're going to use one of these
vertices in the triangle is going to be
one of the two acute angles okay but
usually they use a Greek letter so theta
here we position ourself at this angle
like so and we say okay well what's the
sine of theta well if we go to our
acronym sine is the opposite side over
the hypotenuse so for here the opposite
side that's the side that's across from
the angle that's going to be 3 over the
hypotenuse that's the one that's across
from the right angle okay that's 5 so
the sine ratio is going to be 3/5 if we
want to find the cosecant okay this is
abbreviated as CSC the cosecant we can
just take the reciprocal that's going to
be 5 over 3 another way to think about
this though is instead of the opposite
over hypotenuse you can do the
hypotenuse over the opposite okay the
next one the cosine of theta we're going
to use the adjacent over hypotenuse so
if we're here adjacent means next to
that's going to be this side here that's
4
over the hypotenuse which is five so
that's four-fifths for the cosine now
students sometimes make a mistake they
say well Mario you know isn't five
adjacent to two the angle theta well
that is true adjacent means next to but
the one that's across from the right
angle we're always gonna call that the
hypotenuse so the adjacent side is the
other one that's next to it okay and
then the secant of theta that's the
reciprocal of cosine so seeking is
abbreviated SEC and you can just take
the reciprocal or flip that fraction
over so five over four and then the last
one the tangent of theta we're using the
opposite over the adjacent so tangent we
have opposite that's a cross adjacent
that's next to the angle so that's gonna
be three over four and then the
cotangent we're just gonna take the
reciprocal so that's 4/3
okay so let's jump into some other
examples so you can get some experience
with this so number one we want to find
the six trigonometric functions okay of
this angle here okay so if you're here
at this angle you can see we're missing
this side right here so we have to do
the Pythagorean theorem to find this
missing side so this is a right triangle
here so we've got a squared plus B
squared equals C squared right seven is
going to be our a B squared we don't
know that's the side right here and C
squared is our hypotenuse that's
twenty-five squared this is 625 7
squared is 49 if we subtract 49 from
both sides what do we get we get 576 and
if we take the square root we get 24 so
this is 24 now you might know this
already if you learned your Pythagorean
triples these are integer values so
these are ones that are easy to work
with this one here is gonna be a little
bit more challenging we're to have some
radicals so but for this one now we've
got all three sides let's say we want to
find the sine of theta so sine of theta
equals opposite side over the hypotenuse
right so opposite would be 7 hypotenuse
is across from the right angle so that's
going to be 25 and you've got it if we
want the cosecant of theta we just take
the reciprocal this is going to be 25
over 7 okay how about the cosine of
theta well cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse so see a over H so adjacent
is next 2 that's 24 over the one across
from the right angle that is the
hypotenuse so 24 over 25 if we want the
secant
sec we just take the reciprocal this is
going to be 25 over 24 and then if we
want the tangent tangent is opposite
divided by the adjacent remember
opposites across that's seven and
adjacent is next to so that's going to
be seven over 24 and if you want the
cotangent Co T of the angle we're just
going to take the reciprocal that's 24 /
7